hey everybody I'm Kristian harloff and
I'm Tiffany Smith and our guest for
today is the director of final girl
we've got Tyler Shields and this is what
are you dog show
thank you so much for coming to complete
our movie threesome today thanks for
having me I'm pumped to talk about your
new movie it's a thriller final girl
it's got Abigail Breslin wes bentley and
logan Huffman a little bit about the
movie abigail plays a girl who was
trained from age seven to hunt and kill
serial killers any time you see these
kinds of movies where it's in the woods
at night they're always very dimly lit
but with this I wanted to have almost
like a magical feel so we had massive
lights to kind of create this world
which they existed you've done a lot of
photography and a lot of people talk
about the fact that you get actors to do
edgy or different things how do you
build that relationship with you yet so
the first thing that we did when we got
on set was I had Abigail shave West
Bentleys head when you asked that of
people they have to trust you and then I
had her punch me in the face and that
was a right hook yes she gave me that
needs to be in the DVD I don't know it
might be it might be all right Tyler so
on this show what we like to do is we
put our butts on the line every week
with our who would have thought in any
world that Fantastic Four would opened
up that low and you bet 41 million I did
and you bet 42 million and the actual
number was twenty five point six million
which means so Matt sourwine sent in
loser should have to drink pickle juice
brine every time an actor's name is
mentioned
bring in the fickle juice this is so
exciting oh wow
what should the actor's name be Daniel
day-lewis I like that I didn't look like
too much Daniel day-lewis we talked
about today so thank you sir let's get
into our weekly wager and take a look at
a clip from Straight Outta Compton
you guys you have a unique voice the
world needs to hear
they won't nw8 let's kill them in w-wait
what's the line he has I drink your
milkshake Straight Outta Compton is
opening this weekend I'm gonna say it's
gonna make 26 million definitely going
higher every other meme on the Internet
is straight out of something it's
getting free publicity I'll go 3 2
million you think it's gonna make that
much more than Fantastic Four yeah get
involved by hashtagging loser should how
do you do that in the comments on
YouTube here on Twitter suggest a
punishment hey Tyler you know one of the
things I want to ask you first time
director working with actors
is it more stick by the script or do you
let people improvise some of the best
stuff in final girl is to improv so
they're all being these characters every
week so well that's what I was a lot of
the method acting actually something
we're gonna talk about today coinkidink
there's so much good and bad to it
Robert De Niro done it for taxi driver I
mean he actually got a license and
became a cab driver do you prefer that
your actors are doing this you have to
find the line because like you know when
you live this they start to become crazy
I mentioned before your magic spark yeah
so crazy if you're gonna play that type
of character and you're gonna do it that
well it's really difficult for people to
go home and be like okay holy let me get
to dinner we can't not talk about this
man when we're talking about method
acting one of the greatest method actors
one would think I would yell about it
but he gets a cheers for that he's the
best
Gangs of New York Daniel don't know
they'd be a break my Louis that's right
the last of the Mohicans thank you oh
sorry oh it's no big pickle juice every
time you burp um Tyler any stories you
have about method with your acting on
your movie Alexander Ludwig drank ten
milkshakes back-to-back that's not
anything in comparison to Logan Huffman
legally I don't know if I'm allowed to
say but we can talk to him because he
he's in a loony bin right now so if we
can get a TV in here or something you
can we could talk to him do it hey Logan
how you doing I'm doing great boss just
been set here for a really long time and
I know I got a little weird with final
girl and going dark and math yeah did
you get past that whole shoe fixation oh
yeah yeah dude that's that was that was
a phase that was a part of the process
we talked about this before we shot I'm
fine
clearly he's manipulating us he's using
his acting abilities to lie maybe if you
just showed him a little love instead of
locking him up in there like an animal
let me tell you something if you go near
him he's gonna take your shoes what and
he's gonna do weird things with them I
tried to warn her shoes Oh
hey Logan I'm Tiffany hi Tiffany okay
Tyler he seems totally stable I don't
know what you're talking about
so shoes are great for dance this is not
good I'm starting to dance
look she's dancers no no you don't
understand when he starts to dance he
goes crazy a blast this is really bad
this is bad
look Tiffany's hosting transcend space
and time in spine
okay okay there he goes once he's got
ahold of the funnies like Josh okay six
maybe told you why don't you listen to
Jesus Christ it's the shoe work your
life is smelling the machine I see if
she loves the shoe let's play a game
we're gonna play a little game called
quick draw I'm gonna give you guys the
name of an actor and a movie that they
may have won an Oscar for if they were
in that and they won press this and you
say true whoever says true or false
first and is correct get the point also
I'm sorry this feels really weird that
I'm doing this and I have one shoe on
Cate Blanchet one for The Aviator
surf-off Meryl Streep Julie and Julia
both that is correct
Russell Crowe in Gladiator yes
Oh beautiful
well he shut up Julianne Moore the hours
boss can you tell me what she won for
being Alice clothes still Alice - Alice
and the last one is Daniel Day there
will be blood so that means that you get
to spin the winners we love winning
Christian bring it in
since you got seed do you have a clip
that you would like to share with us say
I have a great clip from the Fandango
lounge of me be method with one of your
correspondence all right let's take a
look have you ever been slapped in the
face do it I love it right oh I gotta
tell you I liked you before I like you
so much more now make sure you guys
follow me on Twitter at Tyler Shields
and click like on this video subscribe
as well and download the Fandango movie
clips app on your smartphone and join us
next week on what is that shoe shoe shoe
Locker can I win with him damn it
Tiffany